Terrain It
's dangerous to go on the defensive at twilight You wrote me that you'll return at night You
haven't told me anything
Why are you like this?
What kind of creature are
you?  You're so understanding, you just take
my words for what they
are, so no matter how selfish I am, it's
not like I'm so uninterested in you that I don't know anything
.
Did you make a strange face? I
remember
you looking for me for a long time Even though I left a note, you still have an
amazing face.
If you're gone And are you
resting in a place like this?My
body's balance has collapsed, so I've been making
adjustments here So
far, sentences, struggles, and lies are all mixed together.
And now I'm so strong
The smartphone about me is cute
Can you wait a minute
So from
next time onwards, from
Acorn's familiar,
Linden term Yes,
Lord Lindell, it's the message leader.
After feeding, the requirement queen